We will now go through an
example, which is essentially
a drill, to consolidate our
understanding of the
conditional expectation and
the conditional variance.
Consider a random variable X,
which is continuous and is
described by a PDF
of this form.
Whenever we have a PDF that
seems to consist of different
pieces, it's always useful
to divide and conquer.
And the way we will do that
will be to consider two
different scenarios.
That X falls in this range.
And in that scenario, we say
that the certain random
variable Y is equal to 1.
And another scenario in which X
falls in this range, and in
that case, we say that
Y is equal to 2.
Let us now look at the
conditional expectation of X
given Y. What is it?
Well, it is a random variable
which can take a different
values depending on what Y is.
If Y happens to take
a value of 1, then
we are in this range.
And the conditional PDF of X,
given that Y falls in this
range, keeps the same
shape, it's uniform.
And so it's mean is going to
be equal to the midpoint of
this interval, which is 1/2.
And this is something that
happens when Y is equal to 1.
What is the probability
of this happening?
The probability that Y is equal
to 1 is the area under
the PDF in this range.
And since the height of
the PDF is 1/2, this
probability is 1/2.
The alternative scenario is
that Y happens to take the
value of 2.
In which case, X lives
in this interval.
Given that X has fallen in this
interval, the conditional
expectation of X is the midpoint
of this interval.
And the midpoint of this
interval is at 2.
And this is an event that,
again, happens with
probability 1/2, because the
area under the PDF in this
region is equal to 1/2.
So the conditional expectation
is a random variable that
takes these values with
these probabilities.
Since we now have a complete
probabilistic description of
this random variable, we're
able to calculate the
expectation of this
random variable.
What is it?
With probability 1/2, the random
variable takes the
value of 1/2.
And with probability 1/2,
it takes a value of 2.
And so the expected value
of the conditional
expectation is 5/4.
But the law of iterated
expectations tells us that
this quantity is also the same
as the expected value of X. So
we have managed to find the
expected value of X by the
divide and conquer method, by
considering different cases.
Let us now turn to the
conditional variance of X
given Y. Once more, this
quantity is a random variable.
The value of that quantity
depends on what Y
turns out to be.
And we have, again, the same
two possibilities.
Y could be equal to 1, or
Y could be equal to 2.
And these possibilities happen
with equal probabilities.
If Y is equal to 1, conditional
on that event, X
has a uniform PDF on this
range, on an interval of
length one.
And we know that the variance
of a uniform PDF on an
interval of length
one is 1/12.
If on the other hand, Y takes
a value of 2, then X is a
uniform random variable on
an interval of length 2.
And the variance in this case
is 2 squared, where this 2
stands for the length of the
interval, divided by 12, which
is the same as 4/12.
So we now have a complete
probabilistic description of
the conditional variance
as a random variable.
It's a random variable that
with these probabilities,
takes these two particular
values.
Since we know the distribution
of this random variable, we
can certainly calculate
its expected value.
And the expected value
is found as follows.
With probability 1/2, the random
variable of interest
takes a value of 1/12.
And with probability 1/2,
this random variable
takes a value of 4/12.
And this number happens
to be 5/24.
Finally, let us calculate the
variance of the conditional
expectation.
Since we have complete
information about the
distribution of the conditional
expectation,
calculating its variance is
not going to be difficult.
So what is it?
With probability 1/2, the
conditional expectation takes
a value of 1/2.
We subtract from this is the
mean of the conditional
expectation, which is 5/4.
And we take the square
of that.
So this term is the square or
the deviation of the value of
the random variable of
1/2 from the mean
of that random variable.
And we get a similar term.
If Y happens to be equal to 2.
With probability 1/2 half, our
random variable takes a value
of 2, which is so much
away from the mean
of the random variable.
And then we square
that quantity.
If we carry out the algebra,
the answer turns out
to be 9 over 16.
And now we can go back to the
law of the total variance and
calculate that the total
variance is equal to the
expected value of the variance,
which is 5/24.
And then we have the variance
of the expected
value, which is 9/16.
And this number evaluates
to 37/48.
So we have managed to find the
variance of this random
variable using the divide and
conquer methods and the law of
the total variance.